across europe the vaccination program
continues
here in france well over a million
people have been jabbed
the pace has increased but now our
problem
looms the astrazeneca vaccine is likely
to be approved for use in europe
later this week but the company says
europe will not
immediately get the number of doses that
it's ordered and paid for
even though supplies to the uk will be
unaffected
european union is furious insisting that
everyone should be treated equally i
call on astrazeneca
to engage fully to rebuild trust
to provide complete information and to
live up to his contractual
societal and moral obligations
the number of the issue lies at this
unassuming factory in belgium
it's been hit by production problems the
uk says the shortfall could be made up
by using
astrazeneca vaccines made in the uk
that's something the company is
reluctant to do
it is a diplomatic and business row but
with a very human dimension
if you count how many people will die
in one month in europe
then we speak about 50 000 persons
in one month so any delay of one month
or two months or three months
will be will be a real disaster
for some though this is a distraction
from a huge challenge and a bigger
picture
malta has vaccinated more of its
population than
any other european country the deputy
prime minister
told me he wanted cooperation rather
than rouse
i'm a proponent and a very strong
advocate for
vaccine solidarity so i believe that
as i say we're in this together this we
we
we're fighting the virus not each other
and i and and
this is a cliche but it's true that as
long as there's a pandemic
somewhere there's a pandemic so
to my mind i think we need to show
more vaccine solidarity between
ourselves and
get over this this infantile
quarreling and there is a glimmer of
optimism
the french company sanofi has announced
it will now manufacture vaccines on
behalf
of pfizer the answer to production
problems may
lie in collaboration not confrontation
adam parsons sky news brussels